yeah biden speech was uh
it was competent and given how many
gaffes we saw on the campaign trail it
was
uh maybe much better than it might have
been it was no doubt a return to a tone
of statesmanship
it was a return yes to the high
production values
of the blue team um but
also i would say the degree to which
unity was
invoked so regularly and has been so
weaponized since the election
i i just find it kind of appalling the
abuse of that term and i
can't help but take it a little bit
personally
so that said he shut down dapple
which you know very good very good job
he
re-entered the us and the paris climate
accord awesome
very very nice he reestablished ties
with the who the world health
organization
utterly necessary even even for those of
us
who have been skeptical about some of
the politicization
that the who has engaged in and he
signed this executive order
on preventing and combating
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity or sexual orientation
cool wait not cool
not cool yeah not well let's just read
the first paragraph good
okay zach you can show my screen
oops this is an executive order from the
day of the inauguration january 20th
on as i said preventing and combating
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity or sexual orientation
excuse me by the authority vested in me
as president by the constitution and the
laws of the united states of america
is hereby ordered as follows section one
policy every person should be treated
with respect and dignity and should be
able to live without fear
no matter who they are or whom they love
children should be able to learn without
worrying about whether they will be
denied access to the restroom
the locker room or school sports adults
should be able to earn a living and
pursue a vocation knowing they will not
be fired
demoted or mistreated because of whom
they go home to or because how they
dress does not conform to sex-based
stereotypes
people should be able to access health
care and secure a roof over their heads
without being subjected to sex
discrimination
all persons should receive equal
treatment under the law
no matter their gender identity or
sexual orientation
that first zach if i may thank you
that first sentence um
[Music]
even just the first two phrases of the
first sentences of this executive order
every person should be treated with
respect and dignity and should be able
to live without fear
is a completely honorable sentiment and
exactly not what this executive order
then proceeds to do
what it proceeds to do is prioritizes
the demands of a very very tiny minority
of people
over that over the rights the
established legal rights
of half of the population since when is
this what democracy looks like
well the problem of course is that you
can read
that in two different ways and it is in
fact i would argue
designed so that we will read it into
different ways that it is a signal to
those who are looking for a particular
change in the law
while um appearing to subscribe
to values that all decent americans hold
and the problem is that there is a an
actually difficult balance that needs to
be struck
between providing people the liberty to
do things like
transition to the gender that they feel
while protecting people who uh have a
right to be protected which is to say
women and so these things it is not
clear how to strike that balance
and it is certainly not going to be a
simple matter
but in doing it this way they have
effectively chosen sides while leaving
the
option to declare themselves um
completely uh uh concordant with
the the values that we all share yeah
the rest of the executive order with one
notable sentence is pretty anodyne
right it just it's it's just it's fairly
generic and exactly as you say it leaves
them open to declare later oh that's not
what we meant
oh we didn't see this eventuality coming
we couldn't have seen what was
downstream of this
and you know of course they can right
it's perfectly clear
that in extending
um effectively extending
rights to trans women these are people
who are born male
who transition to female that they are
encroaching
on uh the rights of women to be
protected
from men in things like sports
competition and
more importantly in cases like when they
are sent to prison
prisons crisis centers um halfway houses
places places
that are single sex for the explicit
reason
that women are a protected class
and this has never before been a class
to which you could simply declare
yourself i am now in that
and um the the vast majority of what you
know what i will continue to call the
truly trans people and now i don't have
a
you know magic magic eyesight with which
determine
at first glance you know who that is but
i will say that the truly trans people
represent i am
certain a small fraction of the people
who are currently masquerading as trans
and um you know this we of course
want to protect uh the rights and the
health and the safety of truly trans
people
uh but doing so in a way that is easily
gameable
and will be gamed and allows those many
people who
are interested in cosplay to
to come into women's spaces is
frankly horrific and i don't understand
how anyone
who has claimed to be interested in
women's rights
or protections for women or a feminist
or any of this i don't see how
anyone and i am sure that biden and
harris both identify with those sorts of
identifiers
um can can be in favor of this if they
have thought even
you know two steps down the road well i
don't even think they are in favor but i
think they are playing politics
and there is a large segment of the
population that can't
track multiple competing values
simultaneously and so
there's a script that basically says you
know
if you're a good person you're in favor
of protecting trans people
i would agree with that but protecting
trans people if that's all you see at
that moment at whose expense and just
just to make this
perfectly clear why are women a
protected class
and why does that protection need to be
maintained especially in light of all of
the gains that women have made
well let me explain it this way um i
liked how that went
yeah i'm just having a little
conversation with so if you want to get
some coffee or something you're uh
you're welcome for you maybe
sure that'd be great um but
let's think about it this way um at a
basic biological
level right nature has not it has been
balanced in some ways but it has been
unfair to women
in the sense of rendering them
vulnerable
you know there's the obvious fact of
males on average being bigger
but there is the um slightly harder to
to grapple with fact of the sexual
asymmetry between men and women
which is to say men are in a much
better position physiologically to
rape women than women are to rape men
right
right a woman raping a man is a
difficult thing for her to accomplish
even if that's what she is
uh desiring to do and the advantages
that bad men will take
of women are well understood well named
everyone is familiar with them
and they are universally understood by
all but the reprehensible few to be
appalling
and and disgusting the power
that bad women have over men is less
well understood
uh has fewer names associated with it
and it doesn't tend to
it's not nearly as likely to end in
violence or unwanted pregnancy
yes and men you know they may not always
uh
resist bad women as they should but they
at least have that power at their
disposal whereas a man can overpower a
woman
um rape her and as you point out where i
was
gonna go next is the simple ability to
potentially inflict a child on someone
right that is a biological asymmetry now
it's reduced for people who
might avail themselves of uh you know
family planning technology
but nonetheless the the ability of you
know this
asymmetry between what a man can do to a
woman and what a woman could do to a man
is justification in and of itself for
protected spaces where women don't have
to worry
about people with male genitals and
gonads
and the idea that
we are somehow in an effort to be good
to a
small number of people who are
involved in a gender transition that we
are going to open
a loophole you know well no man would
exploit that
really an unscrupulous man wouldn't
choose you don't even need to go to have
you met men have you met people
of course people will you know meerkats
would right giraffes would
this you know this is what social
organisms do
some number of individuals in any social
system be they humans or dolphins or
rabbits
will game the system and you know create
a system that is gameable
by executive order and you're going to
get a lot more of it
right and you know an executive order
like this well if it doesn't draw
you know it ought to protect women in
sport right let's just agree that that
would be the right thing to do because
there are major
physiological differences that advantage
people born male
but if your executive order
doesn't recognize that there's a problem
when it comes to prisons
and that a man sent to a men's
prison for a sexual offense who suddenly
decides
that he's trans and prefers to be in a
women's prison
cannot be humored and in fact there are
multiple examples of men
who have done this and then gone on to
uh to assault women so
now it does i mean it does the actual
manifestation
seems to be mostly at um head of
agencies you know so federal
federal agencies um and
i i do feel like it opens up a whole lot
of possibility for downstream but i'm
not sure
i'm not sure for instance what the
effect of this executive order
specifically would be on federal prisons
obviously on private prisons it has no
direct effect i'm not sure about federal
prisons because they're not
agency level well i'm not sure actually
that there's a distinction between
the private and the publicly funded
prisons because the question is the
rights of the prisoners you know they're
sentenced in a in a
a public uh context and so
it doesn't say that the executive order
has an effect on prisons but it signals
a belief in a principle that obviously
is insufficient to deal with
the situation and so does are they going
to reverse course on
this and say yes this is true equal
protection except when it comes to
prisons
no that's not very likely it's not very
likely and so they're effectively asking
the populace
to to buy into a fiction and the more
fictions that people buy into the more
of that cognitive dissonance that they
are that
all of us are asked to participate in
the more fractured our cognition gets
the less capable we are of having a
coherent worldview
and building it from first principles
and you you
you're more likely once you know once
you've accepted some number of these
just
you know just lies about what reality is
you are more and more likely
to say you know whatever i i accept it
i'm gonna go along with it because you
appear to be feeding me something
that's consistent in your worldview and
i don't know how to make sense of it
yeah um so you know we've seen
um a number of these signals about
direction
and we've seen them all delivered in
rorschach
form and i think um you know actually
i don't know if this is the place to
introduce it but
um i did a discussion with james lindsay
and jesse single and there's a segment
of it that keeps coming back up and
jesse has expressed frustration that he
keeps being drawn back into discussions
of it and i don't wish to draw him
back into a discussion okay uh so could
we just
so there's a more natural place to go
there i think perfect can we can we do
the next thing
first um if i if you were going where i
think you are
um there's a there's one more sentence
in the executive order that i wanted to
bring up which is you don't have to show
my screen zack
it is for example transgender black
americans face unconscionably high
levels of workplace discrimination
homelessness and violence including
fatal violence
now early in the summer when the
protests and then the riots were
beginning to become regular parts of
life in portland and many other cities
around the us and even the world
um we pointed out here on um
on this podcast that there was at that
point on the black lives matter home
page
a strange focus on what what we
suggested was a strange but unusual
notable focus on black trans lives black
trans lives matter in fact there was a
there was a
um an organized rally for black major
demonstration the second major one in
new york
yeah so black trans lives what what is
it about black trans like why
this intersectionality in particular and
um
you know there's there's a lot to do
there and i'm not sure this is where we
want to
explore that again but unconscionably
high levels of workplace discrimination
homelessness and violence is the claim
well unconscionably high levels is of
course a wiggle term
that you could claim unconscionably high
levels is any levels
and therefore any any violence against
pick your group
fill in your group here is
unconscionably high in which case this
is
this sentence means nothing in which
case why include it
and what what they seem to be doing is
signaling that they are making some kind
of a statistical argument without
actually having done so so they provided
cover for themselves as
as you would um if as you would if you
had no data
i really want to see the references i am
so tired of seeing this claim
black trans lives are the ones who are
the most threatened there is an epidemic
and you know there are what 400
000 deaths in america that have been
attributed to covet at this point
and i didn't pull up the numbers but
something in the dozens
at the most of um trans people
murdered in the u.s last year which is
you know the thing that is evidence of
the
epidemic of violence and hatred against
trans lives and often specifically black
trans lives and you know that that many
lives
um taken inappropriately terribly etc
is does not a pandemic make no no it
does not
um it's
it it makes you wonder who is served
right like who who
wins with this kind of rhetoric and here
um
here is where i think we can segue to
what you were going to talk about here
so andy noe
you know our friend also um someone who
we'll talk about a little bit later with
regard to the the powell's
dustup um who is a
um portland-based or you know was in
portland for
for his whole life um based journalist
who focuses
on um revealing what antifa is actually
up to and of course has
drawn the ire of of them many many times
and
sometimes public ways a couple of years
ago revealed the fabrications behind
the uh then ubiquitous claims it seemed
that there was
widespread street violence against trans
people in portland and seattle
and um i remember following this at the
time i think it was 2018 but actually
katie herzog and jesse single in their
podcast blocked and reported
uh we're talking about this this week
and they were talking about the
the good work um that andy noe did
specifically
on revealing that a there was a clear
financial incentive
for such people to claim that they had
been assaulted because in almost every
case
um there was an immediate gofundme set
up with several thousand dollars
accruing pretty rapidly to the person
who had supposedly been assaulted
and there was a complete lack of
evidence there were never any police
reports
and of course people hide behind you
know all cops or bastards all of this
but
you know no evidence financial incentive
g
i wonder if this is perhaps a
an epidemic of you know violence against
trans people on the streets of two of
the most progressive cities in the
country
um that is actually a fiction and um
andy certainly
um found evidence to suggest that that
is that it's likely what it serves also
to do though
is not just enrich the individuals who
are making those claims
by lining their pockets with gofundme
money but it also
further creates this culture of fear and
anger
which allows you know blue team and red
team to
go farther and farther apart and look
suspiciously at each other sometimes
armed
um from ever greater divides yes
and um you know at some level the the
category is um
unassailable right why is it that black
trans lives
uh are somehow at the top of the stack
well this
comes from intersectionality the idea
that there is some sort of emergent
nature to the
overlapping oppressions that someone
experiences that you know the
the oppression of you know a black gay
person is more than the sum of the
oppression of black and gay
and no doubt there's some truth to that
but you can't base policy on that and
what's more you can't open a loophole
based on it and expect
nobody to cynically go through it right
so
you know at some level policy
has to be color blind right
it is the blindness of the law that is
its genius
and all of these things that say
actually we can do better than blind we
can enhance it to protect this group and
that group and the other group
all of these things are an invitation
to gaming except in cases where as we
discussed at the top here
you know these things are uh objective
right
i am female therefore certain things
inherently follow and so anyway we just
got to stop being stupid about this if
you open a loophole there will be
people who use it to game the system and
the law has to be robust to that it has
to not allow it
okay and the last thing i would say
though is that this brings us back
around
to what we started with we were talking
about the indications out of the very
young biden administration
i mean we talked about several things
that seemed positive rejoining
the who um the paris climate of course
climate change yeah and i would just say
that in each of these two i think we
need to be cautious of the same
kind of um the two being the who and the
paris climate accord
uh yes um so the who
in principle should the u.s be uh
a very active member of the who sure but
there's a question about whether or not
the who is so compromised by allegiances
that in fact
we are stuck in the position of
effectively not having
a viable who and the fact
of peter dacic being on
the who's task force to determine the
origin
of sars kovi ii in china is indicative
of a
deep kind of corruption right this is
the last person who should be on that
committee and yet
he's there again most positive gloss is
at the very least there's a conflict of
interest there
there's a conflict of interest and it
may be driving and so
um if that is the case then the fact
that symbolically it makes sense to
participate in the world's mechanisms
for navigating health issues and things
like that
is in conflict with what the hell are we
going to do once the mechanisms are
captured we're going to have to do
something
unusual with respect to the paris
climate accords i would say symbolically
speaking
this is great of course we should be
party to global accords on
managing resources like the atmosphere
and protecting us from
heat accumulation on the other hand uh
it ain't a solution right it's more or
less symbolic at the level of its
effectiveness
and if we were ever going to get to
something useful we would have
to have a very frank global discussion
and that would include figuring out
you know what parts of these models uh
actually indicate something how can you
validate them rather than pretending
that because the computer says that
something's going to happen
that it is what other data can we rely
on in order to calibrate
our belief or lack of belief in the
models etc
so can we promote international efforts
for actual alternative energy etc
right and with respect to uh
dapple i would say um i was very much
not in favor of this pipeline i don't
like it but
um i mean you were you protested against
it yeah i did
um but back in whenever that was like
2016 2016 it would have been
um but i want to know what the
alternative
is and i want a net analysis right the
idea of we're not going to do this
because our constituents don't like it
is not good enough the answer is well
what are we going to do
and you know so uh i'm not interested in
the shell game where we pay
attention to the symbolism over here and
we don't check out the net effect of
the policy change so in all of these
cases i would say i remain to be
convinced
and we have to move beyond symbolism and
uh
you know political corruption and
regulatory capture
are uh two of the biggest stories of our
era and we
we're gonna have to to find our way out
of the
very deep hole they've dug for us